inserts for your hplc files are useful  in helping to recover the sample because  it reduces the volume inside for example  these flat bottom glass inserts have the  largest capacity for filling up your  sample so they would be great for being  economical conical inserts have a  tapered bottom with a pulled tip to  allow greater sample recovery and the  poly spring inserts here have rubber  feet that hold the insert firmly in  place so the auto sampler needles path  is not obstructed plastic polypropylene  inserts would be perfect for anything  that is pH sensitive you choose Amber  glasses for light sensitive applications  and clear glass for non-light sensitive  applications now make sure the vial  inserts are compatible with the vial to  secure a tight fit and maximize sample  recovery